in the lobby of Ramsey solutions David
and Regina are with us hey guys how are
you living the team dream how are you
awesome honored to have you where are
you from where do you live or just
outside of st. Louis Missouri and Union
ah very cool welcome to Nashville and
here to do a debt-free scream yes sir so
how much have you paid off one hundred
and forty three thousand dollars love it
and how long did that take total of 38
months excellent and your income range
during that time average between 80 and
120 awesome what do you guys do for a
living I'm a state trooper I'm a massage
therapists very cool very cool well good
to have you guys welcome to Nashville so
what kind of debt was the hundred and
forty three thousand dollars we had our
one vehicle that we paid off and a small
credit card from a home loan improvement
store and the rest of that was a
mortgage you paid off your house way to
go how old are you - 31 31 years old you
have a paid-for house yes sir so weird
you are officially weird thank you you
are weird people
I see weird people awesome guys Wow
what's this house worth probably about
170 with a paid for house at 31 years
old oh just like that man you guys got
on fire so what happened 38 months ago
we took FPU back in January of 2013 at
the suggestion of a family member of
ours and just got on the train and drank
the juice and kept going how much of the
143 was your mortgage 125 most of it
then yes sir
okay so you just once you got to gear it
up you didn't ever let off the gas you
just plowed right on through that's
correct
I mean 38 months you guys I mean this is
crazy Regina was he going nuts or did
what happened here okay that's how this
gets done usually yeah every time one of
us would kind of slow down the other one
would kick it up so that's really fast
thank you to pay off your house and
actually about 80 of that was within the
last 13 months so we hit it pretty hard
so how'd you do me did you get some
extra money from somewhere no we cash
flowed everything you have literally
lived on nothing or you've taken on a
ton of OT or something over time and
late nights and you name it we did it
you've been going crazy when people had
to think you've lost your mind people
had to be making fun of you I all the
time all the time and how you like me
now yeah really
you paid four hundred seventy thousand
dollars 31 years old shut up yes yes yes
so friends make fun of your work work
people fellow workers or family lots of
co-workers yeah you name it we heard
about it not eating out and not going
into places that cost money everything
yeah everybody everybody was but did you
have any cheerleaders we did my parents
have led they've gone through FPU as
well so we kind of got the idea from
them and it took a family member where
we're at to push us along the way and
we've led our own FPU class Wow just
finished up two weeks ago now all right
very cool and so MA you brought mom and
dad with you to celebrate yep Grandma
and Grandpa here with the kids
all right right life is good oh yeah so
now you're an FPU class leader second
generation because mom and dad have let
a class too and then you finally get in
the class before you let it of course
and so when you when you're doing on
fire mom and dad had yeah they're going
louse told you that I told you that tell
me that for three years you weren't
listening yeah and now you're finally
doing it and you tear it up so now
you're leading a class and somebody says
you guys paid off your house at 31 years
old how did you do that what do you tell
them the secret is no just don't give up
you've got to keep fighting and you know
the budget is probably key as well as
just staying on the same page and
working together how do you get people
to sacrifice as deeply as you did it's
man I know these numbers I mean you guys
have been living on ramen noodles I mean
you have not had any life
believe it or not Regina's very and
holistic treatments and things like that
so we haven't had the kids don't know
what fast food is anyway we very healthy
so it's it's not a problem and we you
know we've done okay we haven't we
haven't starved
but how how do you get people to believe
enough to sacrifice that deeply that's
probably the biggest challenge when
leading a class is trying to inspire
people to to make the cuts that that are
really gonna make make the difference
for them you know you can tell them over
and over again that they need to cut
their lifestyle they need to cut their
lifestyle but until they actually start
doing it it's not when you start making
a lot of progress it's it's I mean
accounting for every single penny that
comes into the household and where it
goes and and pushing it out in the right
direction yeah I like Chris Hogan's
saying he says when when when numbers
start working when people do absolutely
and that's that when you start making
your decide you're gonna make your
destiny then things start rolling out in
front of you so we ended up working so
hard and so focused at what we were
trying to do that we kind of actually
forgot about the whole tax situation and
pushed us into the next tax bracket with
several thousand dollars so now we oh by
the fifteenth we owe quite a bit of
money however we'll be able to pay that
cash no problem Wow
well you don't have any house payments
yeah the KGB's got to get theirs yeah
and then you'll be free to go on and go
on about your business yeah you know so
excellent job guys
excellent excellent job thank you what
was the hardest part
Regina mm probably just the sacrifice
and you know telling the kids no we
can't you can't have this extra thing or
we can't go do this so just kind of
trying to be creative and coming up with
things that we could still do as a
family and still you know get out of the
house without spending a lot of money so
that was probably the hardest David
she's not a whiner no she is not a
whiner certainly now he's a freaking
warrior a warrior princess man that's
what you've married into Wow way to go
very cool I mean cuz I tell you I'm
doing this so long it's more about
relationship and more about unity than
it is the math the math will follow and
if you're having to drag somebody the
husband who won't get on board the wife
who's a princess you never drank
something I along it changes the whole
formula it really does and I can't
convince people that like you said
you've been doing it for years you've
been leading a class it's the same thing
you just want grab them around the neck
and go
stop that you know you whiny little you
know but you can't say that because that
doesn't convince people but but exhausts
go through your mind and you guys are
just the opposite of that and that's why
you've had this huge success so
congratulations all right 170 thousand
dollar paid for house there 31 years old
the boy's name sir what what's the boy's
name Oliver Henry and Oliver Regina and
David a hundred and forty three thousand
dollars in debt paid off in 38 months at
31 years old death free mortgage and
everything baby make an 80 to 120 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
you guys if you don't get the YouTube on
that one you miss something those little
boys have been practicing their
professional debt-free screamers that is
a changed family tree right there man
Wow Wow
the mom and dad just beaming with pride
as they should be very very well done
congratulations
absolutely amazing it's the best of the
best guys that's how it's done and it's
it is about relationships
it is about self-control the depth of
your sacrifice effects the mathematics
of how fast you get out and the more
fired up you are the deeper you'll cut
and the more unified you are as a couple
for those of you that are married the
deeper you'll cut and of course the
deeper you cut the more income you have
then to throw at the debt and the faster
you get out of debt it's a very simple
formula but it's all about passion
you've got to run like your hair's on
fire man I mean you got to bust it you
got to get after it you can wander into
debt darling but you cannot wander out
you have to get some fired up your
friends think you've lost your mind and
then you change your life and you have
that moment where you finally say that's
it I've had it when you have that moment
that's when things change it's a special
moment in your life I hope you have it
sooner rather than later I hope you win
fast they did 31 years old man awesome
that is just so wheat this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here I hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you